one of my first major run-ins with the
law we got caught painting Elementary
School like graffiti painting we were
water coloring the elementary school
who was that painting broad daylight we
just finished a train yard popped the
fence oh here's a wall and we just went
some kids were playing basketball and we
were thinking like oh they think we're
so cool they just went and like ratted
on us cops just waited for us we didn't
run or nothing that was the last day I
saw the guys in my crew and then this
guy DMS me on Instagram he goes how's it
been I saw you on tigerbelly talk about
graffiti I'm still doing it man he's
like 40. oh just popped out second
kid or something like that and he goes
yeah his lady did I think he did he
pushed that out himself but he's still
painting from that incident on like
like I got caught for painting like I
didn't even make money doing this we
keep calling that so yeah my mind goes
to a different visual every time